all right the ravens and the texans get
together in houston lamar jackson
deshawn watson let's hear from both of
them on their looming matchup
that's a great quarterback we're going
against and um i say no because of how
dynamic he is and our defense got to
prepare for him um but yeah you can you
can see you can see that he's doing a
great job for his uh his team and and
the offense that they're doing and
making sure they're putting players and
uh the scheme around him and he's doing
a heck of a job and doing
you know numbers in that office so you
know he's doing a good job and you know
he's gonna continue to do that
to the great quarterbacks in the nfl and
lamar jackson blessed with a great
supporting cast i believe if you flip
the two the ravens would still be the
ravens and the texans would still be the
texans a cut below the best teams in the
conference but this is the chance for
the texans with a few extra days to get
some redemption for what happened last
year 41-7 in baltimore get some
redemption for what happened week one
when it looked like the texans were
playing a preseason game and the chiefs
were playing a regular season game
i
look it's 0-0 when the game starts and
anything can happen i just don't see the
texans being in the same class as the
ravens right now shireen
i i'm right there with you and you know
i didn't think that texas were very good
going into the year and so when the
chiefs came out just took it to the
texans and everybody said hey let's just
go ahead and give the chiefs the super
bowl trophy i said hey let's tap the
brakes a little bit because i just don't
think the texans are that good to me
they look like a seven and a nine eight
and eight teams you trade away the best
receiver in football
and and trade for brandon cooks and i
they're just they're not the same
offense we know desean watson holds the
ball too long john harbaugh openly
talked about that he holds the ball too
long the offensive line's bad j.j watts
110 years old and he and he frankly he's
playing like it i love j.j watt but he's
not the same guy he was when he was
winning all those uh defensive player of
the year awards this to me just does not
look like a good team on paper i just
think they get crushed this week again
it's unfortunate for them that they had
to start against the chiefs and the
ravens who probably are the two best
teams in football right now but that's
the way it is and so they're staring
down 0 and 2 right now
shereen you start the week putting baker
mayfield in a body bag now you're going
after jj what you are hanging around me
too much
poor j.j and i do love jj but he just
doesn't look like the same guy he's had
that elbow injury he just hasn't been
the same guy since he won those awards
andrea's to me injuries have really
caught up to him
well and i remember
and it's been several years now he had a
hernia and he got surgery in
philadelphia and he told peter king at
the time he was in such a low point he
thought about just calling it quits then
and there and i admire him for and i
admire any of these guys
they bust their asses to get to 100
knowing full well when they get to 100
they're going to cross that line they're
going to go out on that field and
they're going to do something that's
going to make them less than 100
and get them to have to work to get back
to 100 percent
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports